I don't know I feel like everybody's so
phony nowadays when it comes to race
everybody's so PC trying to prove
they're not racist at every moment I was
at a Starbucks last week I'm talking to
my friend I was like yeah you know my
neighbor he's this Mexican guy and
before I can finish the sentence this
lady stands up and goes hey I didn't
come here to listen to some racist
conversation I was like yeah that'd be
weird if you
did it's a coffee shop who would come
here for that also I said the word
Mexican cuz he is Mexican that's not a
slur that's not a bad word sounds like
you have some problem with Mexicans
you're projecting that on to me right
that'd be like if I said yeah this
four-year-old the other day and you went
whoa you're giving me a boner you
pedophile come
on I don't know